now you talked a little bit about the
backstory of Shaolin fantastic and I
want to know a little bit more about
where you came from your connection to
that auntie and Cadillac like the ties
there hypothetically speaking for a
season 2 do you think that they're
probably going to dive into that
backstory definitely I think season 2 is
gonna be a lot more Chow focused
oh really I think it would definitely be
books and cooks obviously but yeah this
definitely would have to be more of
where he came from why he acts like that
is it still of so many questions you
know they would have to answer them
where's the season two you have no idea
what I've done to put us in this good
situation that dynamic between Shaolin
books is kind of like I think is gonna
it's becoming more like who is the good
guy and who is the bad guy you know it's
all relative to what your perception is
from shouts perspective he is doing a
lot for books you know in a good way and
in books perspective he's doing a lot in
a bad way I guess me coming to yell with
a gun and him running away from his car
that was intense
yeah so it's kind of like it looks like
showers a bad guy but his mind he's
saving his best friend you know get
ready to share with the world I think uh
from how her disco career is kind of
booming and then he's going up my
personal opinion I think Miley should
come to Shaolin section or caddy section
Cadillac let's put some drama in there
well you know Catholic you know so
Cadillac has its eyes on her so that
would be interesting but I hope you
don't get in the way or your best friend
hey it just left me okay I went back to
fat Annie to protect him let's keep it a
buck he's going to college I'm upset at
this time i'm shaoling fantastic I got
to show him what that means it's making
something of myself means losing myself
then what am I making and we bought it
for life so they turn out the lights
you
[Music]